ja da ist wo leben alleine nicht die ihm
folgt und harry tatsächlich warnung
achtung was per se und der spannende
moment
hallo zusammen nebeneinander das ist ein
bild was man so da seid ihr am jahren
nicht mehr gesehen
ja das ist der moment der zeigt dass
sich die brüder in der trauer wieder
angenähert haben die schöneren daneben
wie schön das sind auch die bilder die
sich mit sicherheit prinz philip
gewünscht hätte den lehrbetrieb im
krankenhaus über den streit der brüder
über das interview von megan und harry
mit oprah winfrey war da kommt nichts
gutes bei raus sondern auch am
krankenbett gesagt haben
jetzt laufen sie aber hier sehen wir
camilla und charles laufen und wir haben
eben vielleicht kommen sie gleich noch
mal in die kamera haben wir harry und
william und kate zusammen laufen sind da
ist sehen wir sie laufen daher möchte
ich dass sein dass hier haben die brüder
reden sie reparieren sie gehen
nebeneinander her und wie du schon sagt
dass patricia also dass es
wahrscheinlich genau das was ich philipp
auch gewünscht hätte reißt euch zusammen
ihr seid eine familie und die familie
geht über alles also wer sind die beiden
ist frieden rada kate seite an seite
jetzt sehen wir sie doch noch seite an
seite
es laufen tatsächlich prinz harry und
prinz william eine sehr bewegenden
trauerfeier für den großvater jetzt
gemeinsam zurück zum schluss ja ein
schloss mit so großer bedeutung prinz
harry hat dort seine madden geheiratet
daher könnten wir auch das innere von
saint george szabo alle noch so gut mit
den kleinen lampen das wird sofort
erinnerungen geweckt an diesem
hochzeiten mag damals und jetzt sehen
wir tatsächlich bilder die alle drei und
jetzt auch die brüder zusammen ja hoffen
wir dass das wirklich zwei prinzen
herzen wieder im gleichschritt sind so
jetzt kann man natürlich noch nicht
sagen
oder ob das eben auch sind ja beides
pr-strategen das muss man eben jetzt
auch mal ganz nüchtern
sie ja aber sie hätten jetzt auch sie
hätten auch noch meter abstand zwischen
sicherheiten können und ich finde
irgendwie ist das auch ein schönes
zeichen
ich meine die drei waren jan super trio
kate william henry
es gibt viele viele momente wo die 33
bei wohlfahrt
wohltätigkeitsveranstaltung waren und so
viel spaß hatten und so viel zusammen
gelacht haben bis zu dem zeitpunkt muss
man leider sagen als mengen in das leben
von harry getreten ist es ist eigentlich
eher weg bergab gegangen mit dieser
dreierkombination und vielleicht war es
auch ganz gut dass megan heute nicht
dabei war vielleicht brauchte harry
jetzt auch mal die zeit um diesen moment
für sich und für seine familie zu nutzen
sich diesen moment zu nehmen
und manchmal ist es auch ganz gut wenn
man wenn man denjenigen der einen
vielleicht auch manchmal ein bisschen
bei den rhein redet dann nicht es ist
auf jeden fall ein wahnsinniger moment
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass wir den
diesen moment ja heute so sehen werden
ich dachte dass wir eher vielleicht
kleine gesten aber dass wir die brüder
prinz william und prinz harry gemeinsam
von der beerdigung ihres großvaters weg
gehen sie in tief im gespräch vereint
das ist ein zeichen dass sich die brüder
nach ihrem großen streit jetzt wieder an
er wir sind bild und wir liefern dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren